[Musica]
el 11 maggio del 1997 la guerra fredda è
finita da pochi anni
stati uniti e russia si affrontano però
davanti ad una scacchiera la russia
schiera garry kasparov
probabilmente il più grande scacchista
in carne e ossa mai esistito gli stati
uniti mettono in campo deep blue un
intelligenza artificiale sviluppata da
ibm con l'esplicito compito di battere
garry kasparov e il sesto fatidico match
tra di loro c'è una pressione nell'aria
incredibile commentatori dell'epoca
parlano di brains last stand l'ultimo
baluardo di difesa del cervello umano
mica male il risultato lo conoscete
tutti
vince di blu è la più sonora batosta ma
inferta all'intelligenza umana d'altra
parte gli scacchi sono il vertice
dell'intelletto
pensateci il più grande scacchista mai
esistito viene sconfitto da un computer
che è infinitamente meno potente di
quello che avete in tasca o in borsa
oggi e che per lo più utilizzate per
integra mare per chattare e memorie
queste cavolate qua giusto ne ha fatta
di strada la tecnologia in 20 anni
quanta ne farà nei prossimi venti
proventi anni mia figlia si stava
affacciando sul mondo del lavoro con una
tecnologia che va così che gli devo
dirla alla piccolina basta stare guarda
è inutile che cerchi di trovare uno
sbocco lavorativo di studiare tanto
nella migliore delle ipotesi fra
vent'anni le macchine faranno quello che
potresti fare tu meglio più velocemente
magari anche a costo zero in qualche
maniera giusto nella peggiore delle
ipotesi lo diceva paolo prima ci sono
giocheranno e faremo dei cervelli in
vitro
io non credo che sia questo il paradigma
si parla tanto della era
dell'intelligenza artificiale ma sarebbe
più corretto
oggi il parlare dell'era
dell'intelligenza ibrida io mi chiamo
federico vigorelli porro di lavoro aiuto
le persone e le aziende a gestire il
cambiamento sia tecnologico che non
l'affermazione che ho fatto poco fa
sull'intelligenza ibrida volendo un po
forte mi piacerebbe costruire questo
paradigma facendo un passettino avanti
nella storia di garry kasparov della
famosa partita un po tutti sanno quello
che non tutti sanno è quello che capitò
il giorno dopo è il 12 maggio del 1997
garry kasparov si sveglia nella sua
stanza d'albergo e rosica ma rosica
tanto tanto non gli va proprio giù
questo fatto di essere stato battuto da
una macchina da una stupida ignorante
limitato a macchina programmata da
chissà che nerd nel suo basement
nell'occhio ma lui il grande campione ci
deve essere stato un trucco
ci deve essere un grande maestro che
dietro lia nelle quinte che fa finta di
essere l'intelligenza artificiale per
forza con questa idea nella mente
garry kasparov nel corso dell'anno
successivo crea un nuovo formato di
torneo di scacchi che si chiama free
style quindi in cui uomo e macchina si
sfidano facciamo fast forward al 2005 un
particolare torneo in cui si sfidano si
affrontano i cosiddetti centauri quindi
nelle squadre miste in qualche modo
intelligenza artificiale e intelligenza
umana lo scopo è proprio cercare di
capire chi avrà la meglio quale
combinazione già al tempo era acclarato
che fosse impossibile battere un
intelligenza artificiale realmente forte
quindi in realtà la risposta dovrebbe
essere abbastanza ovvia se andiamo con
la logica
faccio un esempio se io adesso volessi
fare un doppio a tennis non è che se mi
metto a giocare con roger federer
aumenterò le sue probabilità di vincere
probabilmente roger federer vorrà
giocare da solo contro due avversari
piuttosto che
di fianco che non posso che limitarlo
ecco negli scacchi questo non fu ciò che
accade non solo un campione di scacchi
assieme ad un intelligenza artificiale
forte vince va regolarmente contro le
singole intelligenze artificiali ma a
vincere questo torneo
in particolare furono due ragazzi due
giocatori francamente mediocri che non
sono passati alla storia se non per
questo 3d e 2 schiappe se volessi essere
un po crudo assieme a tre computer tra
intelligenze artificiali che
singolarmente erano tutte e tre molto
più limitate deboli rispetto
all'intelligenza artificiale più
importante del tempo che si chiamava
hydra
se ci pensate è pazzesco è la prima
dimostrazione che se noi uniamo
l'intelligenza artificiale con quella
umana
otteniamo qualche cosa che è molto di
più della somma fra le parti questi due
ragazzi cosa facevano facevano
analizzare la partita alle tre computer
in caso di accordo un po tipo minority
report per chi ha idea sceglievano di
fare la mossa che era suggerita ma la
magia avveniva quando c'era il
disaccordo allora entravano loro
analizzavano la partita con dei criteri
differenti da quelli delle intelligenze
artificiali cercavano di capire
interpretare perché l'intelligenza
avessero dato delle valutazioni diverse
rispetto alla mossa da fare
e in questo modo prendevano una
decisione loro questo portò alla
vittoria
non fu una vittoria né dell'intelligenza
umana né dell'intelligenza artificiale
fu una vittoria del processo di
collaborazione di integrazione di
ibridizzazione questo fu vero nel 2005
negli scacchi ma è vero tanto quanto
oggi nel 2019 in qualunque ambito in cui
noi possiamo pensare di applicare
l'intelligenza artificiale e questo
deriva da alcuni limiti che
l'intelligenza artificiale a che sono
costitutivi sono proprio legati a come è
pensata oggi
innanzitutto un primissimo limite che
quando si parla di intelligenza
artificiale si è soliti usare un motto
che l'fbi games r billion examples la
vita artificiale e inizia a un miliardo
di esempi questo non è un segreto per
nessuno e le reti neurali realmente
robuste forti devono addestrarsi sui set
di dati molto corposi milioni se non
proprio miliardi questo è dovuto al
fatto che ogni volta che noi diamo un
dato nuovo all'intelligenza artificiale
questa aggiungerà un piccolo pezzettino
al proprio modello di predizioni che
aumentera l'affidabilità la precisione
delle sue predizioni o delle sue
classificazioni che quello in cui
l'intelligenza artificiale eccelle
pensate a come apprende l'uomo è così
noi non abbiamo bisogno di avere milioni
di esempi ed i dati per arrivare a un
buon livello di affidabilità
questo da un lato chiaramente rende
l'intelligenza artificiale
potenzialmente molto più accurata nel
lungo periodo ma nel breve periodo
quando si tratta di dover essere
flessibili di dover anche cambiare le
proprie valutazioni
siamo molto avvantaggiati un
intelligenza artificiale non è in grado
di uscire dal solco tracciato dal suo
apprendimento
perché per sterzare un sistema che si è
addestrato su milioni e milioni di dati
ci vorrà molto tempo non bastano pochi
dati verranno considerati come anomalie
noi uomini siamo in grado di prendere
l'unicità delle situazioni e valutarla
caso per caso in maniera che
l'intelligenza artificiale oggi non è
ancora in grado di replicare il secondo
limite di cui dovremmo essere
consapevoli e legato al fatto che
l'intelligenza artificiale eccelle in
modo supremo nei cosiddetti sistemi
chiusi
pensate agli scacchi abbiamo appena
fatto questo esempio come ha fatto
di blu e poi le sue versioni successive
a eccellere così tanto in questo gioco
così complesso che se andate a vedere il
numero di permutazione di partite
possibili negli scambi si dice che siano
di più di quanti atomi ci siano
nell'universo megale a mappate tutte
l'intelligenza artificiale ne ha potuto
giocare milioni di partite contro gli
esseri umani ci sarebbe voluto uno
sforzo davvero epocale ha potuto giocare
contro se stessa milioni di volte
se sostanzialmente presa l'intelligenza
artificiale era si fa giocare contro se
stessa questo perché gli scacchi il gol
qualunque altro gioco a cui si applica
l'intelligenza artificiale sono sistemi
chiusi le regole degli scacchi sono
quelle da 1500 anni ma provate a
cambiare una stupidissima piccolissima
regola aggiungete una riga alla
scacchiera rendetela rettangolare
invertita e torri coi cavalli un
campione di scacchi non avrebbe problemi
ma neanche un giocatore mediocre ad
adattare il proprio modo di giocare
l'intelligenza artificiale andrebbe in
panne diventerebbe un bambino che non ha
neanche mai visto gli scacchi perché non
è in grado di generalizzare il suo
apprendimento cambi una virgola e cambia
il mondo devi ri addestrarla da zero per
noi uomini è l'esatto opposto
noi siamo in grado di applicare in modo
flessibile ciò che abbiamo appreso e
pensate nella conduzione di un'azienda
nella strategia aziendale come potremmo
farla gestire un intelligenza
artificiale
quando le regole cambiano un minuto per
minuto ora questo non vuol dire che
siano da buttare via assolutamente
l'intelligenza artificiale chiaramente
dobbiamo gestirli i sistemi chiusi in
tasche compiti abbastanza stretti e
ammettiamo di avere un intelligenza
artificiale davvero capace di fare
questo
arriviamo però a un terzo limite che è
il cosiddetto black box set dove lo
voglio raccontare con un aneddoto
immaginate di essere in procinto di fare
l'acquisto più importante per qualunque
italiano la playstation 5
scusate errore e per me quello la prima
casa dovete acquistare la prima casa
l'avete scelta con cura ne avete viste
molte vi siete anche avete investito
emotivamente avete fatto un offerta al
venditore il venditore l'ha accettata
tutti speranzosi di recata in banca per
farvi dare i soldi che gli servono per
comprarla il direttore vi accoglie molto
gentilmente molto molta cura della
vostra di questo momento recepisce tutte
le vostre informazioni vi dà anche
qualche consiglio e poi mette tutti i
vostri dati all'interno di un computer
passa qualche minuto e il direttore
riguarda cambia espressione diventa un
po contrito e gli dice vigorelli
io i soldi non glieli posso dare ma come
mai un buon lavoro faccio il fedex
speaker so un contratto a tempo
indeterminato le fideiussioni di mia
mamma mia nonna mia zia e anche del
calcio come e macchina dixit cioè
abbiamo sviluppato un nuovo sistema di
intelligenza artificiale che predice la
probabilità che lei possa ripagare o
meno il muto e con un 75 per cento di
probabilita ci dice che fra 12 anni e
mezzo lei non pagherà qualche rata ma vi
andrebbe bene una risposta del genere ma
assolutamente no e non solo non vi
andrebbe bene il gdp are vi dà ragione
mi dà il diritto di avere una
spiegazione ma il problema che sorge è
che il povero direttore di banca non
saprebbe darmi una risposta
proprio per questo black box effect che
è talmente forte che non solo non
potrebbe darlo il direttore non ve lo
darebbe nemmeno il suo capo nel capo del
suo capo ma facilmente non ve la darebbe
nemmeno il data scientists che la
programmata questa intelligenza
artificiale perché le reti neurali che
permettono determinati livelli di
affidabilità sono talmente complesse e
soprattutto non ragionano per di
identificazione di due o tre elementi
che fanno decide
sì o no ma sono e delle intricate reti
di neuroni artificiali che prendono una
decisione con dei pesi che a occhio
umano impossibile andare a vedere ora
chiaramente la tecnologia si sta
attrezzando sta cercando di sviluppare
un paradigma e l'intelligenza
artificiale chiamato explain knuble e
yari per cercare di evitare questo
problema questo è chiaro però per noi
esseri umani diventa fondamentale
diventare ormai di rai tre lingue
italiano inglese lo sappiamo ma anche
dovremmo iniziare a parlare artificiale
se cioè e riuscire a interpretare quella
complessa lingua per alcuni addirittura
direbbero aliena in cui l'intelligenza
artificiale prende le sue decisioni
perché di fronte a un cliente di fronte
a un paziente a cui noi dobbiamo dare
delle spiegazioni
dovremo saper gliele spiegare e non
dovremo agire nei in modo fideistico e
la macchina ragione né però scartare
queste questi sistemi che invece
potrebbero avere veramente ragione sta a
noi capire integrare come due ragazzi
della storia e riuscire a dare una
spiegazione al nostro interlocutore
anche ammettendo però di avere una
spiegazione efficace quindi di aver
superato il black box effect
c'è un quarto è forse il più
problematico di tutti i limiti che
abbiamo risposto finora che è quello che
l'intelligenza artificiale
tutto è fuorché neutrale nelle sue
decisioni
abbiamo già parlato oggi di come
potremmo in qualche modo associare
l'apprendimento delle macchine a quello
dei bambini
il bambino come la macchina non ha un
modello precostituito del mondo se lo
costruisce sulla base di ciò che gli
viene dato ma cos'è che viene fornito
all'intelligenza artificiale dei dati e
i dati sono pieni di pregiudizi
questo problema è quello che ha portato
amazon qualche anno fa a chiudere il suo
programma di intelligenza artificiale
per fare screening di curriculum e
quello che sta creando dei problemini
oggi a apple con la apple card
avevano creato dei sistemi degli
algoritmi sessisti
ma non perché ci fosse un esplicito
sessismo chiaramente l'intelligenza
artificiale non ha il concetto di
sessismo non ha la volontà di essere
sessista
ma prendete l'esempio di amazon se voi
date a un intelligenza artificiale
i dati di tutti i dipendenti di una
grande azienda come amazon e cercate di
far predire l'intelligenza artificiale
quali di questi profili avrà più
probabilità di crescere e diventare un
manager un executive all'interno di una
grande azienda occidentale che cos'è che
scoprirete che incredibilmente chi è che
cresce
gli uomini bianchi come davvero e
l'intelligenza artificiale quando gli
chiede rete sentimmo fra questi 100 cv
chi è che dovrei favorire dei maschi
bianchi se ci sono cascati amazon e
apple capite che questo è un problema
reale ma non è un problema della
tecnologia non è un problema dei data
scientist non è il loro mestiere
conoscere i dati di base conoscere i
pregiudizi
questo è un lavoro più sociologico noi
dovremmo conoscere i dati intervenire
nel momento in cui la nostra azienda
il nostro la nostra società sta
lavorando sulla costruzione di un
intelligenza artificiale e aiutare a
uscire da questo problema spiegare i
denti capire quali pregiudizi possono
essere nascosti all'interno dei dati
considerando che l'intelligenza
artificiale molto più furba di noi se
anche noi togliamo la colonna del genere
perché sappiamo che magari verrà fuori
sessista
ma per co correlazioni si dice in
statistica e cioè va a pescare quegli
elementi che si associano all'essere
donna ad esempio c'è scritto femminile
all'interno del campo degli hobby perché
è il capitano della squadra femminile di
volley
oppure si è andato ad una scuola o hai
fatto un percorso di studi
particolarmente associato all'essere
donna ora
questi quattro limiti che ho evidenziato
e le 4 strategie che si collegano ci
danno la strada che dobbiamo seguire che
ciascuno di noi deve seguire se
realmente vogliamo andare nella
direzione dell'intelligenza ibrida
fintanto che rimarremo bloccati nella
retorica giornalistica che vuole che
l'intelligenza artificiale
un giorno sia un angelo sceso dal cielo
che con uno schiocco di dita un battito
di ali risolverà tutti i problemi del
mondo curerà il cancro risolverà i
problemi di diversità e ci porterà su
marte e il global warming oppure
dall'altra parte un demone un essere
abietto che rischia di sostituirci
grecia rischia di toglierci ciò che è
veramente nostro la nostra mente e non
ci stacchiamo da questo dualismo
facilone non capiremo che è
completamente inutile cercare di lottare
di remare controcorrente di lottare
contro l'intelligenza artificiale per
cercare di mantenere il predominio su
compiti su cui partiamo perdenti in
partenza la capacità di analizzare
grandi nuvole volumi di dati la capacità
di eseguire compiti con alta precisione
i sistemi chiusi
queste sono strumenti sono miglioramenti
sono strumenti che ci permetteranno di
migliorare il nostro modo di essere la
nostra stessa intelligenza alla
potenzieranno e ci permetteranno di fare
così ancora più leva su quelle
caratteristiche realmente uniche
dell'intelligenza umana la creatività
l'empatia la flessibilità cognitiva la
capacità di leggere le situazioni in un
contesto che ho avuto a punta
continuamente uscendo dal seminato del
nostro apprendimento e vedendo le cose
con un respiro più ampio
solamente così saremo in grado di
costruire una mente che sia molto
infinitamente più umana di quanto lo sia
stata finora
grazie
[Applauso]